disney sky high is a charming superhero
movie about growing up
getting through high school and saving
the world if you only ever watched it as
a kid however
you're missing a lot of the movie's best
puns details and dynamics
these are the parts of sky high only the
grown-ups get
sky high's protagonist will stronghold
has multiple tenacious d in the pickup
destiny posters on his wall
this r-rated 2006 stoner comedy focuses
on a pair of slackers on a quest to
become the greatest band of all time
not exactly the kind of thing the kids
watching the pg rated sky high would
tend to notice
but that's not the only interesting bit
of memorabilia in will's room
he also has a poster of the aquabats a
celebrated real world superhero rock
band
known best for their costumes and sense
of fun not only does that put will's
tastes in line with the coolest nerds of
the 90s
it works in universe perhaps the
aquabats are actually superheroes in the
world of sky high
beyond this will has sketches a lot of
space-themed window stickers and posters
and even a guitar leaning up against the
wall behind a weight training bench
at a normal high school he probably
would have actually been cool
with or without super powers layla's
pacifist attitude is a common theme
throughout the movie
she even refuses to show off her
plant-based powers because doing so
violates her principles
she thinks a person's power should only
be used when the situation demands it
does she live up to this code well not
really
layla uses her abilities to give her
crush an apple and make a flower at a
restaurant table wilt
not exactly high stakes moments of life
and death so perhaps it's not surprising
that she seems to be violating her own
principles
when she's seen sporting a leather bag
not many kids notice leyla's bag
or the other inconsistencies in her
philosophy but adults will catch on
quickly
of course adults also understand that
the teenage years are the age at which
one learns that principles are
complicated
layla's figuring out her own values and
how best to carry them out
still someone should probably tell this
girl about the wide world of
fake leather goods does principal powers
look familiar
kids look at her and see any other
grown-up but adults will likely notice
something familiar in her face
that's because she's played by the one
and only linda carter
who portrayed the titular heroine of the
1970s wonder woman tv
series this reference was actually meant
to be more overt
but copyright got in the way originally
the plan was for principal powers to
sport a pair of gold bracelets
referencing wonder woman's legendary
bullet deflection accessories
unfortunately warner brothers the owners
of the wonder woman copyright
objected thus the bracelets were
banished but as sky high fans know
this doesn't mean there were no nods to
carter's amazonian history in the film
i'm not wonder woman you know while kids
likely will just consider this a
throwaway line every grown-up in the
audience will get a chuckle out of the
reference
additionally nurse specs is played by
cloris leachman
who played wonder woman's mother in the
same show like any school
sky high is a learning institution full
of teens forming their first political
opinions
the nuance of this dynamic most likely
escapes kids
but adults catch every single line take
this exchange in response to the
students learning about how they'll be
sorted into the school hierarchy
power placement she sounds fascist layla
might be a little dramatic but she's not
wrong
this school runs on the kids on the hero
track being separated from those
destined for hero support
otherwise known as sidekick status
speaking of sidekicks
a running joke revolves around the
preferred terminology for less powered
individuals
which any adult can recognize as
reminiscent of many real-world debates
i believe the preferred term is hero
support for now
then there's the scene where josie and
steve try to work out their schedules
and josie mentions a particularly
amusing upcoming appointment about a
government agency
many people find particularly evil
when are we briefing the president on
supervillain infiltration of the irs
there is perhaps no joke that flies
higher over kids heads than this one
but their parents get a good chuckle out
of it figuring out once taxes can
certainly feel like being ensnared in
some supervillain scheme
sky high is jam-packed with puns and
allusions to idioms and media that few
kids will notice
at most kids might catch the oxymoron in
warren peace's name
but not know the classic work of
literature by leo tolstoy it is based on
his name also refers to the conflicting
nature of his parentage
his mother is a superhero and his father
is a villain
it's punny as well as thematically
resonant adults may also catch a sly
reference to another well-known kurt
russell role
after taking a distress call the
commander dramatically informs jetstream
that there is trouble downtown
then repeats himself big trouble
downtown this is a clever nod to 1986's
big trouble in little china
which starred russell as a tough trucker
battling an ancient sorcerer
meanwhile while gwen grayson is the main
villain of sky high
her name contains references to some
pretty heroic comic book characters
gwen stacy is well known for being peter
parker's tragic girlfriend and more
recently
as the web slinging spider gwen and
dick grayson was the real name of
batman's sidekick robin
who eventually became nightwing gwen's
role in sky high
can be interpreted as a hybrid of these
two characters robin the original
sidekick
has often been the butt of cultural
jokes gwen's vengeance and villainy take
root in the fact that she is
unappreciated and misunderstood in a
similar way
on the flip side gwen stacy began as the
ultimate dream girl for spider-man fans
to idealize
but both she and sky high's gwen grayson
are more than they seem
the cast of sky-high is chock full of
comedy and sci-fi stars
but one of the most recognizable cameos
is also uniquely invisible to most kids
tom kenny the voice of spongebob
squarepants and jill talley
the voice of karen plankton's
computerized wife from the iconic
nickelodeon cartoon
the actors who are married in real life
appear briefly as mr and mrs timmerman
kids won't tie the couple to their
animated characters but adults are a lot
likelier to recognize the familiar voice
actors
after the timmermans purchase a home
from the strongholds early in the movie
they move in and comment all unpacked
and the movers didn't break a thing told
you we didn't need that extra insurance
of course little do they know that
they're moments away from a floating
school
falling out of the sky and smashing
their house to smithereens
fortunately will and his friends save
their new home just in the nick of time
if you look closely the costumes in sky
high play a subtle role in both
foreshadowing future events
and misleading the audience for example
lash's stretchy sleeves are reminiscent
of a striped prison uniform
perhaps foreshadowing his eventual
reveal as a villainous character
then there's gwen grayson's pink color
scheme the traditionally feminine color
stands in stark contrast
to the fact that her super villain
persona royal pain
is always assumed to be male it's also
an interesting color choice considering
that gwen's former identity
sue tenny blended into the background as
a geek
her superpowers were poorly understood
at the time resulting in alienation from
her classmates
a bold color like bright pink isn't one
you'd likely associate with a super
villain
or a mild-mannered wallflower which
makes her reveal as gwen
and her ultimate plan all the more
surprising
the soundtrack of sky high is full of
hits only adults will recognize
tears for fears 1985 classic everybody
wants to rule the world
starts the film off strong other hits
include can't stop the world released by
the go-go's in 1981
the smith's 1984 song please please
please let me get what i want
and just what i needed by the cars which
came out in 1978.
this soundtrack represents the many cues
sky high takes from 80s media
fans of the breakfast club which came
out in 1985 will recognize the familiar
archetypes recalled by sky high's
characters
warren mirrors the brooding bad boy john
bender magenta calls back to the
withdrawn alison reynolds
zack the goofy geek reflects the
character of brian johnson
claire standish is the principled layla
and will is characterized by the same
defining athleticism as andrew clark
just before everything goes sideways mr
boy the hero support teacher
has the following exchange with layla at
the refreshment table of the homecoming
dance
hey there layla you look like you could
use a drink
no thanks oh don't worry the bubbles are
just gingery
he seems to be under the bizarre
impression that layla would think he's
blithely offering alcohol to children
beyond earning a laugh from the adult
audience this moment drives home that
sky high's central teenage characters
may be a little more savvy and
self-aware than the adults around them
whether or not these dynamics are
actually true in high school is up for
debate
but grown-up viewers will likely
remember the teenage feeling of thinking
that the adults in their lives were
oblivious
to what was really going on when all
american boy comments on the importance
of avoiding clashing color schemes
between heroes and sidekicks
he's taking a light jab at batman and
robin's garb
the movie is full of similar references
to its various inspirations
that only the most comics savvy members
of the audience will get
sky high derives its story from the long
history of superhero comics
and the film is creative enough to craft
its own relationship to the canon of the
medium
loving jokes about tropes are just one
piece of that puzzle
sky high pokes particular fun at hero
and villain origin stories
especially the difference in experience
between those who are radioactively
transformed
and those who inherit powers from their
parents there's even a joke at the end
that ties up the story of ron wilson
the bus driver and a charmingly goofy
jab
at chemical induced superpowers oh yeah
and ron wilson bus driver fell into a
vat of toxic waste
he now works for the mayor defending the
city from giant robots toxic waste has
been a key element in the origin stories
of iconic characters ranging from the
joker to the teenage mutant ninja
turtles
so it's only fitting that sky high would
work in a nod to this bizarre method of
gaining superpowers
wilson is an unlikely superhero and
that's the point
these super-powered stories are silly
and unrealistic
and that's why we love them after her
evil plan is foiled by will and his
friends
gwen grumbles in detention i went
through puberty
twice for this younger children might
hear this line and ask their parents
what's puberty it sounds bad it may
set parents up for a somewhat awkward
conversation but it will also give them
a chuckle
since adults will recall all too well
the discomfort and awkwardness of
puberty
then again as the movie's last line
states
but hey that's high school
sure puberty sucks but you can also
develop your own sense of style during
it
find a group of friends and learn to
balance the desire to belong with the
desire to be true to yourself
most importantly though you learn that
there is no going back to childhood
regardless of what sky high says and
you're on a one-way flying bus ride to
adulthood
but somehow we all get through it just
like will does kids might not get the
humor of this line
but the movie is helping prepare them
for the age at which it'll eventually
click
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]